thousands of people in California are
under evacuation orders this morning
because of rushing floodwaters and
mudslides some areas are already digging
out from the muck and debris people
affected by the deadly wildfires are
most at risk of having their homes
destroyed Carter Evans is in Malibu one
of the cities hit by those recent
wildfires Carter good morning good
morning we got a solid day of rain and
more is on the way it's a big concern to
burn areas like this because in the
mountains around here there's just not
much left to hold the dirt in place now
heavy downpours across Southern
California prompted flash flood warnings
and mandatory evacuations for about
4,000 homes once the rain slowed piles
of mud ash and debris blocked several
roads highways were slick there were a
lot of accidents this area is just not
used to so much rain at once
in Northern California many people
affected by the deadly campfire were
forced to evacuate again this time
because of rising floodwaters now first
responders had to rescue several
residents in Butte County and in Los
Angeles a firefighter rescued a man
clinging to a tree in the rushing water
of the LA River
he was later treated for hypothermia now
we should get a break from the rain
today but there is more weather coming
in this weekend the good news bianna
it's not expected to be as bad as the
last storm that is some good news we'll
take it Carter thank you